yourself and judi dench you haven't done
this yet you want to be working together
soon I believe we are in the movie of
cats
musical path who are you giving Gus is
the cat at the theater door my name as I
ought to have told you before is really
asparagus but that's such a fuss to
pronunce that they usually call me just
gas but look if you're making a group
I'm really the invitation is so so open
but you might well ask how did you
prepare for being a cat how do you
prepare for being a cat well at the
moment I'm looking for the inner [__]
the mugginess that she's within us all
not doing very well at it I thought of
going on a cat's diet unit weekends just
eating cat food so yes that out but and
I've always thought that tinned cat food
smells as if it might be rather tasty it
isn't
[Music]